مستمرون مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه للتطورات
في السودان حيث الهدنه في يومها الثاني لا
تخلوقات والازمه الانسانيه حاضره طبعا
وتزيد الصحه العالميه التي دقت ناقوس
الخطر استوقعت المزيد من الوفيات في ظل
نقص الخدمات مشيره الى ان اكثر من 60% من
المنشات الصحيه في الخرطوم مغلقه لكن
الخبر اللافت هو اعلان وزير خارجيه جنوب
السودان ان البرهان اكد لرئيس جنوب
السودان سلفا استعداده للقاء احمد خارج
الخرطوم وان انه ما يزال يحاول اقناع احمد
مواطنين مسالمين دارين ياكلوا لقمه الايش
المشكله بقى خطيره علينا
[موسيقى]
الناس المساكين وقراييل الصناعيه للنظل
بيشتغلوا اليوم باليوم وانت يا النفرين
لكم في الكرسي انا الدائري منكم بس تهزوا
[موسيقى]
ومع استمرار المواجهات في السودان والجهود
الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق النار اعلن
البيت الابيض عن العمل مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار لوقف
العنف وتامين المسارات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان وقف اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر
رغم بعض الخرقات بالاضافه الى عمليات
القصف العشوائي التي اسفرت عن مقتل
المدنيين بينهم الامريكي هو الثاني حتى
الان هذا واكد البيت الابيض على مواصله
العمل لتامين خروج كل مواطن امريكي يريد
مغادره الاراضي السودانيه
من جهته مشاهدينا قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا ان الاتحاد يرحب بالهدنه
الانسانيه في السودان ولكنه يريد الوصول
الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
كنا نرحب بطبيعه الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه
من سميه في السودان بعد ايام من من الصراع
ولكن صحيح هناك اعلانات هنا هناك
لاختراقات وانتهاكات لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر
دعواتنا لنتراخ المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت دائم
اعلن الجيش السوداني التصدي لهجوم لقوات
الدعم السريع على مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم وقال الجيش انه
كبد قوات الدعم السريع خسائر فادحه بحسب
البيان هذا وتعمل جيش قوات الدعم السريع
بمواصلات خرق الهدنه المعلمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودين المواطنين ماشيين
ماشيين
شرطه المحليه
لانه ما في قوه يعني تحميم
يحمي نفسه
حملت قوات الدعم السريع المجتمع الدولي
مسؤولياته تجاه خلق الهدنه من قبل قيادات
الجيش السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم التزام
قيادات الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد تعدد مراكز
القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوات الدعم
السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه مواقعها
بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض المعسكرات
وسوبا في وقت واحد
دعا وزير الماليه السوداني وزعيم حركه
العدل والمساواه جبريل ابراهيم دعا الشباب
الى تشكيل لجان شعبيه لحمايه المدن
المتاثره بالحرب وقال جبريل ابراهيم في
تغريدات على حسابه على تويتر ان الوضع في
مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
يتسم بالفوضى العاربه مشددا على ضروره
التحرك لايقاف الماسات هناك على حد
تعبيرها
باتا معبر ارقين البري الفاصل بين الحدود
المصريه والسودانيه امل الفارين من
اشتباكات السودان خصوصا من مدينتي الخرطوم
وام درمان الكثيرون تحدثوا عن خطوره
الاوضاع وصعوبه الرحله من السودان وصولا
للحدود المصريه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
نحن الان في منفذ العرجيل اخر نقطه
الحدوديه لعبور المصريين والسودانيين
والرعايه الاجانب الذين يهربون من جحيم ما
يحدث في السودان الى مصر
الضرب
والقاف الخرطوم وضرب بيقع عشوائي بقى
الضرب يعني
حد صالح
[موسيقى]
شديد
وضحايا شديد
والغنابل بتقع في خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروفه هنلقاه ولا مش حنلقاز
ومن خلال هذه الحافلات سينتقلون الى
وجهتهم المقبله مدينه اسوان التي تبعد عن
هذا المنفذ حدودي 500 كلم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينطم ينضم الينا من باريس عبر
الهاتف الدكتور محمد فيل سفير الجمهوريه
جزر القمر لدى فرنسا وعضو لجنه مبادره
الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الصراع في السودان
اهلا بك سعاده السفير يعني اليوم كل العين
على المبادرات التي يمكن ان تقدم للخروج
بحل سلمى ويعني تجنب مسيره طويله من
الاقتتال ما هي المبادرات التي ستتقدمون
فيها بهذا الاطار
اولا السلام عليكم
رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي هو رئيس جزر القمر
سيد خامه الرئيس عثمان الغزالي قام
بمبادره اولها
كان الاتصال
بالجهتين المختلتين من اجل
اسكات الاسلحه
ودعوتهما الى طاوله الحوار
ثم بعد ذلك بعد ما ادرى
المكالمتين مع
الجهتين استطاع ايضا ان يعرض عليهما
خريطه عمل هي في الحقيقه تهدف الى
دعوه الجهات المعنيه بالوضع السوداني الى
طاوله الحوار
وكذلك
دعوه المجتمع
الى ان يقفوا على جانب الاتحاد الافريقي
من اجل ايجاد حل طريقي وهو في الحقيقه
الخطاب الذي
يستعمل من طرف رئاسه الاتحاد الافريقي
وبالتالي يعني الكل اليوم يدعي الى الحوار
والجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات ما تطرحونه
اليوم هل طرحتموه مع الاليه الثلاثيه
والاليات الرباعيه هل طرحتموه على اطراف
الصراع هل هناك يعني قبول من اي من هذه
الاطراف
نعم يعني ما يثلج الصبر ان الجهتين
المعنيتين بالوضع
قبلت ما عرض عليهما السيد الرئيس ولا شك
انه يشتغل مع
المنظمات الدوليه كلها وعلى وجه الخصوص
الاتحاد الافريقي الذي
هت ان
استعدادهما للاشتغال معه يعني كمنظمه يعني
نحن في الحقيقه يعني وهذا ما يسند الصدر
ايضا ان الجهتين
رغبتهما في ان يكون الحل حل افريقي
باعتبار يعني ان الاتحاد الافريقي احدى
المنظمات الاقليميه التي تختص يعني والتي
تدار اليها تؤكل اليها موضوع تسويه
النزاعات بين الاطراف هناك اليوم بين طرفي
النزاع بين احمدتي وبين البرهان اذا يعني
كما قلت بانكم عرضتم المبادره على الطرفين
وهم
محل قبول هل ممكن بالساعات المقبله ان
يجلسوا على طاوله المفاوضات ما التنازلات
التي ممكن ان تقدم هل نحن امام وقف طويل
لاطلاق النار ام ماذا
وفي الحقيقه الهدف الاول هو اسكات الاسلحه
الجهتان ابدت
رغبتيما في ان نصل الى هذه المرحله لابد
من اسكات الاسلحه فورا وفي الحقيقه تلك
الجهتين ابدت
استعدادها
لهذه المرحله وفي الحقيقه المرحله
المهمه بعد ذلك
رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي
هو في مرحله اعداد خريطه عمل ان شاء الله
الخرطوم هل سيزور وفد الخرطوم للجميع نعم
هذا ايضا من الامور يعني فورمه فورمه
تتوفر الشروط الامنيه
فينتقل المرحله الماضيه لم تستطيعوا
الوصول الى الخرطوم يعني
وطرح المبادره بشكل مباشر على الطرفين
بسبب عدم
عدم يعني
الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار ما الذي يضمن
اليوم بان يلتزم الطرفين باطلاق بوقف
اطلاق النار وهل هم مستعدون لاستقبال
الوفد
في الحقيقه نحن في مرحله
المفاوضات في هذه النقطه بالضبط لكن يعني
الجهتان اعلنتا كما قلت لكم استعدادهما
لاستقبال يعني وفدا مثل هذا سواء داخل
الخرطوم او خارج الخرطوم لكن بيني وبينكم
استطيع ان اقول لكم ان رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي يرغب في ان يزور او هو
يهدف الى ان يزور الخرطوم في الايام
المقبله لكن شريطه ان تتوفر الشروط
الامنيه بالضبط
شريطه ان تتوفر الشروط الامنيه سيزور
الخرطوم وبالتالي هل يعني ستتكثف
الاتصالات مع طرفي النزاع بالساعات
المقبله خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن هدنه يعني
فرضا الجانب الامريكي نوعا ما لثلاثه ايام
ولم يلتزم بها الطرفان مئه بالمئه هي يعني
تخرق بين وقتها الاخر
انا في الحقيقه ما قلت لكم استطاع الرئيس
ان يتصل
بالفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان
الفريق محمد حمدان دادلو
خلال
الشخصيتين ابدت رغباته رغبتها في ان
يستقبل تستقبل الرئيس وايضا في قبول ما
عرض عليهم عليهم الرئيس فبالتالي يعني في
الحقيقه نود او نرجو
المبادره كما قلت تتضمن بالمرحله الاولى
وقف لاطلاق النار واسكات الرصاص بالمرحله
الثانيه تتضمن ماذا بما ان طرفي النزاع
متعنت اليوم ويحاول كسب اوراق يعني اوراق
رابحه لوضعها على طاوله المفاوضات
يعني لا يمكن ان ادخل اكثر في التفاصيل
لكن ما استطع ان اقول لكم الان ان يعني
بعد اسكات الصوت لابد ايضا من مرات جويه
تسمح لايصال
الاعانه التي في حاله اليها
المدنيون وكذلك الناس الذين يجدون انفسهم
الاخوان اخواننا السودانيون الذين هم
مصابون بهذه
الخطيره يعني المرحله المقبله ان شاء الله
تكون مرحله ايصال الاعانه التي هم في حاله
اليها
وبالتالي انتم نعم انتم الان ما زلتم
بالمرحله الاوليه وهي وقف اطلاق النار ليس
هناك تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه المبادره بانتظار
تنسيقها بشكل مفصل اكثر مع الاطراف
الامميه اتحدث عن اللجنه الثلاثيه واللجنه
الرباعيه شكرا لك سفير جمهوريه جزر القمر
لدى فرنسا وعضو لجنه مبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي لحل الصراع في السودان
تعبنا نحن ما حنطلع من بيوتنا معها نطلع
نحن عم نموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد احنا
اولادنا نقوموا من الصباح عشان يجيبوا لنا
مويه لغايه بالليل مويه عشان نشربه نحنا
مع حد وين حد وين يا ابو وين يا حماتي يا
اخي خافوا الله فينا خافوا الله فينا لا
حول ولا قوه الا بالله
[موسيقى]
وصلتنا من ارسال الجيش السوداني تعزيزات
للخرطوم هذا واشارت هنا مصادر الى ان
القوات هذه التي نتابعها بهذه الصور جاءت
من ولايتي من ولايتي النيل الازرق
والجزيره ومدينه عطبره في ولايه نهر النيل
اذا تعزيزات جديده للجيش السوداني الى
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
كده الطابور طويل من التعزيزات العسكريه
للجيش السوداني من جنوب الخرطوم الى داخل
الخرطوم طبعا هذا ينذر
بارتداء تحدثت المعارك والاشتباكات
بالساعات المقبله بعد انتهاء الهدنه
مشاهدينا نعود الى الارض ونقل الصوره من
هناك من منطقه المعموره جنوب الخرطوم
مراسله العربيه الريان الظاهر
ريان يعني الصوره معك من هناك على ما يبدو
كيف تبدو الحركه بعض المحال مقفله بعضها
مفتوح
وماذا عن يعني اوضاع السكان انسانيه
قبيل قليل كنا باحدى المحال التجاريه التي
فتحت ابوابها
لمده زمنيه معينه او توقيت معين ومن ثم
اغلقت ابوابها كحال عدد من المحل التجاريه
الان معظم المحلات التجاريه او جميعها
يعني غربت الشمس هنا في السودان وبالكاد
تكون مغلقه وجدنا هؤلاء الباعه المتجولين
نريد ان نعرف ونستفسر اكثر ونرصد حركه
المواطن والحركه الشرائيه وللامانه نفذت
كثير من المواد الاساسيه وللاسف حتى
المياه المعدنيه بدات تنفذ من المبردات
ومن ارفف المحال التجاريه وربما المواد
الموجوده الان
بمخازن هذه المحال قد لا تكفي لاسبوع وهو
ما ينبئ به خطر قادم للمواطن السوداني
الذي
يعاني من شح الموارد والمواد التموينيه
والنفاذ المواد الاساسيه نحن هنا نرصد
يعني اراء ايضا وبعض الاستطلاعات لهؤلاء
الباعه وايضا وجدت ان ارفف المحال
التجاريه قد بدات تخلو من الفاكهه
بدات تقل فيها الخضروات فلذلك سنستطلع
عبد الله مرحبا
والله العربيه مرحب بكم اول حاجه كيف
الحركه الشرائيه للمواطن هل في اقبال على
الخضروات والفواكه ايوه ناعم جدا
بطاطس بالف جنيه يعني
هسه
فعلا في غلاوه الاسعار
طبعا لكن طبعا في باجي من اطراف العاصمه
من المزار الاطراف الخرطوم ده بتيجي كله
الصباح تبعنا يعني ازار معقوله ينباعي
الزواج من الفاكهه وشنو اللي ما موجود ما
بيستطيع المواطن شرائه
دي انواع موجوده القديمه مخزنه بس طبعا
تستوردوا جديد لا لا جديد ما في طريقه لكن
الليله صباح اليوم في موز زياد داخل جديد
وكده
ما يملك نقد كيف بتتعاملوا هل بالتطبيقات
البنكيه ممكن تتعاملوا
عمليه شراء يعني مرحبا
انا جيت اشتري موز كان هناك كنت جاي فطبعا
احنا متعودين هنا على ناصه الشارع ده
بنيجي هنا ناخد منه الموز اي فاكهه عنده
بناخدها منه يعني
الله يحرق لحد الان كويسه ما كعبه
المكان 200 بعد صلاه المغرب بنفتح حاليا
ده زمن اغلاقكم
بنفتح الصباح يعني من الساعه تسعه لعشره
كده على حسب التوقيت
المواطنين فعلا في الشارع برضو مرات
بيوقفونا بنبيع
يعني ما في مكان او محل حاليا حالكم كحاله
الباعه المتجولين انتم حاليا في الشارع
يعني في الشارع كيف الاوضاع حاليا هل
المنطقه خطره ولا عاديه كيف بتقدروا
تشتغلوا تمارسوا عملكم والله لحد الان
الوضع هنا غايته امن ما في حاجه بس بعد
الارتكازات في الطريق لفه افريقيا جامعه
افريقيا
نحن طبعا بنجيب من السوق المركزي
الارتجازات لحد الان الصباح هنا برضو كان
في ارتكاز في المحله الصباح بعد العربيات
زي الثلاثه والاربعه ارتكزوا اخذ حاجات من
وفاته
لا لا هم برضو بيشتروا مني انا عادي يعني
استطلاعات لمواطن قام بشراء بعض الفاكهه
وايضا
لهؤلاء الباعه المتجولين الذين يتخذون هذا
الشارع مكانا للعمل
والبيع رصدنا هذه الحركه الشرائيه التي
تبدو نوعا ما جيده يعني ربما النسبه برضو
لاغلاق عدد من المحالات التجاريه وعدد من
الباعه المتجاورين الذين غادروا يعني
الشارع هم فقط
يوجدون الان وسيغلقون الان يعني نشهد
اغلاق هذا المكان
نعم شكرا لك ريان قبل ان اختم هل رصدتم اي
ارتال عسكريه على ما يبدو ان ريان لا
تسمعنا شكرا لك مراسله العربيه ريان
الظاهر حدثنا من جنوب الخرطوم
اكد وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان انا رئيس
مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهان اكد لرئيس جنوب السودان موافقته
على لقاء قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان خارج الخرطوم واوضح وزير خارجيه
جنوب السودان ان محاولات اقناع حماه للقاء
البرهان ما زالت مستمره
عبرت بريطانيا عن قلقها اذا التقارير التي
تفيد بان الطرفين اخفق مره اخرى بالوفاء
في التزاماتهما حول الهدنه ودعت قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع على وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وانهاء العنف بالاضافه الى السماح
بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وحمايه
المدنيين العاملين في المجال الانساني
الى ذلك مشاهدينا دعا الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش اطراف النزاع
المتصارعه في السودان الى وقف القتال في
البلاد شديدا على ان القتال لن يكون حلا
للصراع بين القوتين دعا قاده السودان لجعل
مصالح شعبهم اولويه
وفي المسلسل المعاناه معاناه السودانيين
المدنيين يشكون من رصاصه الدوشكا الروسي
ويقولون انه يخترق جدران المنازل ويصيبهم
باصابات بالغه فلنتابع
رشاش الدوشكا الروسي صمم في الثلاثينات من
القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدرا الى
3500 متر
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
وفي الاخر التطورات عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان قال مراسل العربيه ان نحو سبع
طائرات عسكريه تصل يوميا الى بورت سودان
للاجلاء بالتنسيق مع الجيش هذا ووصلت احدى
طائرات الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده
السعوديه محملات محمله باثنين شخصا كما
تمر عمليات الاجلاء الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث
مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال
بالحافلات الى بورسودان ثم الى ميناء جده
وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره في طرابلس
واستقبل مطار مع تقيه الدوليه
من افراد الجاليه الليبيه في السودان بعد
اجلائهم هذا واكدت الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا
واكثر من 20 سوريا وعدد اخر من الرعايه
بالخرطوم قدم او قدموا من مطار بورتسودا
من مدينه بورسودان مراسل العربيه نزار
مقداوي نزار عمليات الاجلاء كيف هي الصوره
من هناك الايام ما زالت مستمره الاعداد
الموجوده
وكيف يعني تسير عبر البحر او عبر الجو
حاليا
عمليات الاجلاء متواصله بدات منذ الحادي
والعشرين من هذا الشهر عبر البحر وبدات
منذ الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر عبر
مطار بورسودان الدولي حتى الان ما تم
اجلائهم تحديدا نحو مدينه جده عبر البحر
اكثر من 22 تم اجلائهم ينتسبون لاكثر من
65 دوله وصلوا الى بورسودان واكملوا كافه
الاجراءات المتعلقه بالاجلاء وبمغادره
السودان
فيما يلي عمليات الاجلاء عبر المطار هنالك
نحو ست الى ثمانيه رحلات يوميا تهبط
الطائرات العسكريه ما تهبط فقط في مطار
بورسبان هي الطائرات العسكريه لان المطار
مغلق بموجب القرار الذي صدر من السلطات
السودانيه باغلاق المطار الجوي لكافه
الرحلات الجويه الدوليه والدوليه لذلك
يحدث الاستثناء فقط الطائرات التي تجلي
الرعايه وهي الطائرات عسكريه تصل الى
بورسودان في المطار ومنها الى عدد من
القواعد سواء كان في جيبوتي او في عدد من
مطارات المنطقه والاقليم والعالم اما
بحريا فتتواصل حتى اللحظه عمليات الاجلاء
التي تمضي بصوره يوميه بواقع خمس الى ست
قطع بحريه تصل الى مدينه بورسودان تحديدا
في الميناء الشمالي وتقوم بنقل رعايه
مختلف الدول العالم منهم من يمضي الى
ميناء جده ومنهم الى عدد من الموانئ
البحريه في عدد من دول العالم هذا هو
الموقف تستمر هذه العمليه تحت اشراف
ومتابعه من قبل الجيش السوداني وادارات
مختلفه من الشرطه والجوازات والهجره
وبوجود لعدد من ممثلي الدول والسفارات هنا
في مدينه بورسودان
نزار يعني ايضا بموازاه ذلك هناك رحلات ما
زالت تصل الى مطار جده الان الرحلات التي
تسير عبر البحر وعبر الجو من اين والى اين
الرحلات التي تسير من السودان تنطلق كانت
في اليومين الاولين تنطلق من قاعده عسكريه
في مدينه ام درمان تملا عدد من رعايه
الدول الاوروبيه بريطانيا الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا بعدها مباشره من يوم
الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر بدات
الرحلات من داخل مطار بورسودان الدولي هذا
المطار الذي هويات تماما لاستقبال
الطائرات العسكريه يعمل على مدى 24 ساعه
بتنسيق بين الجيش والشرطه واداره الطيران
في السودان ومختلف الوحدات الامنيه
والعسكريه لتنسيق هذه الرحلات التي تصل
الى الى مطار بورسودان بعدها مباشره تنتقل
هذه الرحلات اما الى
البعض القواعد في جيبوتي او تنتقل الى مصر
او الى تونس او الى المغرب او الى الاردن
او الى اسطنبول هذه هي ابرز المواجهات
الدوليه والدوليه نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره
يتم اجلاء من هناك
نعم شكرا لك نزار على كل حال سنبقى نتابع
معك ومع الزملاء عمليات الاجلاء التي بدات
منذ ايام والتي من المتوقع ان تستكمل
بعدما مددت هذه الهدنه الى ثلاثه ايام
شكرا لك نزار مقداوي حدثنا من بورتسولات
حاصل يعني استغلال استغلال ذاته بشع الان
من
صات ويعني التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب سعر
الباص كله خمسه مقاعد لكن يعني عندنا
ثلاثه
نذكر مشاهدينا بالتطورات الميدانيه في
السودان فرغم الهدنه المعلمه المعلنه تشهد
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اشتباكات
مستمره بين طرفي النزاع وهما الجيش
السوداني طبعا وقوات الدعم السريع ويظهر
لنا هنا ان الاشتباكات تركزت في محيط
القصر الرئاسي والواقع طبعا في وسط
العاصمه
السودانيه قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت هنا
الجيش وقالت انه هو من هاجم قواتها بمحيط
القصر الجمهوري وارض المعسكرات وسوبا في
وقت واحد ونجد هنا مشاهدينا ان الاشتباكات
امتدت الى مناطق في محيط القياده العامه
واداره المرافق الاستراتيجيه الجيش اعلن
هنا تصديه لهذه الهجمات التي تشنها
مجموعات الدعم السريع ويظهر لنا ايضا
مشاهدينا اشتباكات في المناطق المحيطه
بمطار الخ الدولي كما نشاهد هنا وايضا حي
المطار السكني
وعن قناصه الدعم السريع المستمره في اطلاق
النار في مطار الخرطوم وبحري وام درمان
وفق اعلان الجيش السوداني من الخرطوم الى
ولايه غرب دارفور فقط تجددت هنا
الاشتباكات ايضا في مدينه الجنينه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع
الاحياء السكنيه كما نشاهد هنا
برمضان كان
يعني عشره
وحول جهود السعوديه بشان المساهمه في
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب عبر موانئ جده
بالبحر الاحمر وصلت الفرقات الفرنسيه لغه
الى جده وعلامتها اكثر من 400 شخص قادمين
من السودان هربا من الاقتتال الزائر
الان بدا نزول
الاشخاص على متن او رعايه بعثته هموم
المتحده ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي
ترافقها احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس
من حرس الحدود وكذلك جنود من حرس الحدود
يرافقونها في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه
الاولى طبعا الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات
الطبيه هم يقومون به الان النزول والمتوجه
مباشره الى مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي
خصصتها الصحه وهي هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي وكذلك السلطات السعوديه وتامين
صحه وسلامه رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده تحمل
هذه الفرقاطه قرابه ال400 شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه هناك السلك الدبلوماسي لعدد من
الدول سواء الدول من اوروبا وكذلك امريكا
وهم ايضا سوف يستقبلون بعض رعاياهم من
بعثه الامم المتحده يتواجدون الان هنا على
الرصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول
او نزول ايضا المزيد من بعثه الامم
المتحده ورعايته الامم المتحده الذين
وصلوا للتو الان
ساهمت سفينه امانه السعوديه باجلاء مئات
الاشخاص من مختلف جنسيات العالم مسجله
بذلك اكبر عمليه اجلاء من السودان حتى
الان فلنتعرف مشاهدينا على هذه السفينه
ونعود
سفينه امان السعوديه تقوم باكبر عمليه
اجلاء من السودان السفينه ترفع علم
السعوديه منذ 44 عاما
ايطاليه الصنع تملكها شركه نماء للتجاره
الدوليه عرضها يصل الى 23 مترا وطولها
لمئه وثمانيه واربعين مئات الرعايه
الاجانب استخدموها لتنقلهم من ميناء سواكن
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
يصلون لوجهتهم المستقره وتغمرهم فرحه
النجاه يلوحون لها شكرا امانه على الامانه
هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم تقصف
يعني رعب كان فظيع من محمد معانا
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان فيه يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما قال
لنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني
منظم ما شاء الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم
قاعدين يعطونه ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع
جدا سهل الحمد لله
تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم قالوا لهم نروح على
الميناء البري البحري
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى الزميل هاني الصفيان
من ميناء جده حيث وصلت سفينه صينيه تنقل
رعايه صينيين لجثه من السودان الصوره معك
كان يتفضل
نعم اهلا بكم مجددا واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا على رصيف من اجل الاسلامي
الواقع غرب السعوديه الان تقف سفينه صينيه
ولكن هذه سفينه سفينه بالاصل هي السفينه
نفطيه ولكن
لصعوبه الامر هناك في السودان فاضطرت هذه
السفينه الى اجلاء
مواطنين من الصين او من ابناء جلدتهم على
هذه الحامله وهي حامله نفط يعني هذه من
المفترض ان هذه السفينه هي مخصصه اصلا
للنفط وكانت تقوم بمهمه في نقل اعمال
نفطيه ولكن اضطرت الى حمل عدد من مواطنين
الصينيين واجلائهم وكانت اقرب نقطه لهم هي
ميناء جده الاسلامي يتوقع ان يكون علامتنا
هذه السفينه قرابه 60 شخص من الجنسيه
الصينيه قدموا من بورتو سودان او بورتو
طبعا الان هي تقف على هذه الرصيف او تقف
السفينه على هذا الرصيف وفي استقبالها
الموظفين وكذلك منسوبين من جده الاسلامي
طبعا هناك
عدد من الجهات الامنيه التي تقوم ايضا
بالاشراف على الوضع الحالي هنا على الرصيف
من منها حرس الحدود وكذلك الجهات الخاصه
بالادارات الصحيه والخدمات الصحيه وكذلك
ايضا يوجد القنصل ايضا والسفير الصيني
وعدد من موظفي السفر الصينيه الذين
يضعونها في هذه اللحظات اللافتات وكذلك
اللافتات ترحيبيه وايضا
هي وعلم الصين ترحيبا
بوصول هؤلاء
المواطنين الصينيين طبعا السعوديه اليوم
او تحديدا نتحدث عن مدينه الجده هي اصبحت
اقرب نقطه وتستعين بها دول عديده نتحدث
اليوم عن اكثر من 58 دوله استعنت في
السلطات السعوديه من اجل تسهيل مهمه وصول
مواطنيها الى مدينه جده كون ان مدينه جده
هي الاقرب وهي الامن وايضا هي مناسبه
لوقوف سواء الفرقاطات او ايضا السفن
التجاريه او ايضا حتى السفن النفطيه وكما
هو نشاهد الان في هذه اللحظه وقوف سفينه
نفطيه صينيه هي اصلا في الاصل ومعده
ومخصصه لحمل النفط طبعا هنا نشاهد ايضا
السفير الصيني وايضا الملحق العسكري في
الصين وايضا بتواجد منسوبين من السفاره
الصينيه هم في استقبال
المواطني مواطنيهم وكذلك ايضا في اللحظات
التي ننتظر فيها نزول هؤلاء الصينيون
الذين قدموا من
بورتسودان والذين سوف ينزلون في هذه
اللحظات طبعا هناك ايضا من الجهات
الحكوميه
ما قدمته السعوديه ايضا دعما ومسانده
للدول الاخرى التي ترغب بوصول مواطنيه هنا
الى مدينه جده وفرت لهم مقر خاصه واماكن
خاصه وكذلك حافلات اليوم كانت في ساعات
الصباح الاولى كانت هناك اكبر خطه ايجار
واكبر عمليه اجلاء لعدد من رعايه من جنسيه
مختلفه نتحدث عن اكثر من 1670 شخص من 40
جنسيه وصلوا الى السعوديه نتحدث ايضا عن
فرقاطه
فرنسيه وهي فرقاطه لورين والتي تقف لاول
مره ايضا على هذا الرصيف وصلت وتحمل على
متنها اكثر من 400 شخص ولكن هم 400 شخص من
رايه الامم المتحده او بعثه الامم المتحده
في السودان من خلال ما واجهوه من هناك من
ازمات وخاصه عندما رصدنا في النشرات
السابقه لبعض حالات الاصابات التي رصدناها
وكانت هناك حالتين اصيبت جراء شظايا من
ذخائر وتم نقلهم مباشره عبر هلال او
الاحمر السعودي الى اقرب المستشفيات التي
عدت لهم طبعا في هذه اللحظات ايضا هناك
الجهات حكوميه وامنيه من قطاعات وزاره
الداخليه التي تقوم ايضا باشراف على سلامه
هؤلاء
الواصلين حتى يتاكدون ايضا من سلمتهم
وايضا هناك الجهات الصحيه تتاكد من اي
فروسات
يعني الان سيتم اجلاء هؤلاء الرعايه
واخراجهم من هذه السفينه الى اين سيتم
ارسالهم هل يعني هناك طائرات جاهزه لنقلهم
الى بلادهم ام انهم سيباتون في جده
طبعا بكل تاكيد هناك طائرات خاصه يتم
التنسيق فيها مع الجهات السعوديه مع
السفارات دوالهم وتحديدا سفر الصينيه هناك
طائرات سوف تقلهم مباشره لديهم الخيارين
الخيار الاول اما اقامتهم يمكثون لمده يوم
او يومين وبعد ذلك مغادرتهم الى بلادهم
الى الصين او مغادره مباشره الى الصين
بالترتيبات والتنسيقات مع السفاره الصيني
على كل حال هاني سنعود اليك فورا يعني
بدء اجلاء هؤلاء من من السفينه شكرا لك
هاني نصفيان وراس العربيه حدثتنا من جده
[موسيقى]
وصلت اول طائره تقل رعايه قادمه من
السودان الى مطار ستانستيد في قرب العاصمه
لندن بعدما اجلتهم الحكومه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
وقف العرق اناناس مواطنين مسالمين دارين
ياكلوا لقمه الايش
المشكله بقى خطيره علينا
كل حاجه يعني الناس
المساكين
اليوم باليوم وانت يا النفرين انا الدائري
منكم بس تهزوا
تستفقوا
قضتوا نظام البشير اصبحوا خارج سجن كوبر
الذي يعد من اكبر واقدم سجون العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لكن ماذا عن الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير سؤال تصدر المشهد
السوداني بعدما كشف الوزير السابق احمد
الهارون وهو احد ابرز رموز نظام البشير عن
هربه وهروب قيادات اخرى تابعه للنظام
السابق من سجن كوبر
اوضاع داخل السجن بخروج كل النزلاء يوم
الاحد 23 ابريل 2023 من السجن عنوه
حتى خلا تماما من نزلائه وسجيانه فيما عدا
قله لا تتجاوز العشره من قاده وضباط
وافراد وبناء على طلب القوه المتبقيه من
قوه السجون تحركنا لموقع اخر خارج السي
تحت حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع كلاهما
تبادل الاتهامات حول هذه القصه
تحديث الجيش اكد بان البشير وبعض قيادات
حزبه كانوا ولا يزالون محتجزين في مستشفى
علياء العسكري قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات لكن
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت قيادات مواليه
للبشير بالامر وبالتامر وفق ما قاله
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
يوسف عزت للعربيه العناصر الاسلاميه داخل
الجيش انا لا اتهم كل الجيش الجيش ليس كله
حركه اسلاميه هنالك ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك
جهات داخل الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك
جهات ضباط اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراحه
هذه المجموعه
سجن كوبر مشاهدينا الذي
سلطت عليه الاضواء امتدت الاشتباكات اليه
وتعرض لقصف مدفعي مما ساهم بهرب مئات
السجناء منهم سجناء محكوم عليهم بالاعدام
هذا السجن سجن كوبر هو السجن المركزي في
البلاد ويقع في مدينه بحري بالقرب من
النيل الازرق بالعاصمه الخرطوم تبلغ مساحه
السجن حوالي خمسه الاف متر مربع وتم
تصميمه على شكل هندسي يحاكي سجون بريطانيا
بعدما تولى مهام اداره هذا السجن الجنرال
الانجليزي كوبر خلال فتره الاحتلال ويضم
السجن 14 قسما من بين هذه الاقسام قسم
مخصص للمدانين باحكام الاعدام واقسم
للمعتقلين السياسيين وبطبيعه الحال قسم
للمحكوم عليهم باحكام طويله وقصيره يبعد
السجن مشاهدينا عن المستشفى العسكري نحو
10 كيلومترات اي حوالي 17 دقيقه
ما موقف اطراف الصراع في السودان من خروج
رموز نظام البشير من السجن
الجيش السوداني سلطه اداره السجون خارج
نطاق اختصاصنا وتحت مسؤوليه وزاره
الداخليه
الدعم السريع لا سيطره لدينا على السجون
في السودان وهذه مسؤوليه الشرطه
الميليشيات المتمرده اجبرت شرطه السجون
على اطلاق سراح النزلاء قيادات المواليه
للبشير في الجيش هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق
سراحه
اداره سجن كوبر اطلقت سراح نزلائه بسبب
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء والاعاشه خروج
قيادات البشير من سجن كوبر صدمه وانتكاسه
لشعب السوداني نحن غير معنيين باي بيانات
من اي جماعه او افراد خرجوا من السجون
مغادره قيادات النظام البشير للسجن امر
متوقع وبعضهم يطلبون دوليا
معنى مشاهدينا من واشنطن عبر سكايب كاميرا
في مركز افريقيا بالمركز الاطلسي
الامريكيه اهلا وسهلا بك سابدا يعني مما
كتبته حول موضوع الازمه السودانيه ومما
يعني علقت عليه بان الكل اخطا في التقدير
تحديدا الجانب الامريكي والغربي في
الحسابات مع الرجلين كيف اخطا
في الحوار السياسي وحوار حول اصلاح القطاع
الامني بينما لم تكن لديهم اي نوايا
لتطبيق تلك الاصلاحات اعتقد ان هذا هو
اكبر خطا ارتكبناه
ايضا يعني بهذه النقطه هناك من يعتبر بان
حتى المجتمع الدولي يعني خدع وكان يعلم
بانه مخدوع لكنه لم يحرك ساكن طيله الفتره
الماضيه
يعني ما الخديعه التي انطلت على المجتمع
الدولي هنا
اعتقد باننا المنظور التاريخي فيما يخص
السودان اذا ما عدنا الى محادثه السلام
وكثفه التي انهت الحرب بين الشمال الجنوبي
السودان
حول اصلاح القطاع الامني وما شاهدناه هو
ان الجنرالان حينها اتفقا على تلك
الاجراءات وبعدها لم يفي بوعودهما
شاهدنا ذلك مرارا وتكرارا وحتى مؤخرا قبل
عام ونصف الجنرال برهان جلس امام المنوفيه
الخاص وقال له بانه لن يكون هنالك انقلاب
في البلاد وبعد خمس ساعات فقط الجنرال
برهان قادم الانقلاب فلست افهم لماذا على
الاقل من ناحيه التاريخيه نستمر بتصديق كل
ما يقال لنا من قبل هذين الجنرالنت اعتقد
بان السبب هو لرغبتنا في تصديقهما وليس
لانها ما اعطانا الادله بل فقط لاننا نريد
ان نصدق ما يقولونه هو ان نصدقا بين
الدولماسيتنا لها الاثر المرغوب ولكن
الحقيقه عكس ذلك
ايضا استاذ كامل هناك بعض التقارير التي
كانت تتنبا بحصول مواجهه عسكريه بين
الطرفين قبل ان تحدث هذه المواجهه برايك
لماذا يعني لم يحرك الغرب ساكنا خصوصا ان
المبعوث الاممي كان موجود هناك اللجنه
الثلاثيه والرباعيه كانت موجوده هناك
وكانوا متفائلين يعني بشكل كبير بالانتقال
السلمي وهنا ايضا انت تقول بان الجنرالين
قال شيء وكانوا يخططون ويحضرون شيء اخر
في قاعات المفاوضات السياسيه قد جار لنا
بينهم يستعدان لحكم المدني ولحكم انتقاليه
جديده اما في شوارع الخرطوم فقد شاهدنا
اعاده نشر القوات والجنود والمدرعات
الثقيله وحتى المدفعيه تنقل الى داخل
المدينه وشهدنا الجنرال في مواجهه
الليله بعد المحادثات السياسيه
ويتمركزان في مواقع اساسيه حول المدينه
فالادله الوحيده التي حصلنا عليها نستطيع
نشير اليها هي الاستعداد للحرب ولم يكن لك
اي شيء يشير الى الاستعداد للسلام او
للحكم المدني من ناحيه ومن قبل الجيش وهذا
اكثر ما يقلقنا
نحن نعيش الظروف التي نشهدها
يعني الانتقال والمسار الديمقراطي ومن لا
يريد وبالتالي يعني هذه سيكمل الطرفان
بهذا الموضوع بحسب خبرتك الشخصيه بالتعاطي
مع الملف السوداني كيف كان يمكن للدول
الغربيه تجنب الوصول الى هذه المرحله من
النزاع وكيف كان يمكن التعاطي مع الطرفين
بطريقه ممكن ان تجنب النزاع السودان هذا
المسار الدموي
من اعطى الشرعيه لحاضرين
وسمحنا لهم باللعب الادوار السياسيه
واعترفناه ادركنا بان من يملكه
لم نفعل ما يكفي لرفع ودعم اصوات المجتمع
المدني وقوات الحريه والتغيير والسياسيين
المدنيين نعم كلهم منقسمون وضعفاء وصحيح
كل هذه الجهات بسبب بالاشكاليات لكنها لم
تقتل احدا وليس لديهم قوات جويه تقصد مدن
اليوم فاعتقد اننا سمحنا لانفسنا بان
تفرض علينا الشروط المحادثات من قبل
الجنرال وكان يجب ان نفض العقوبات على
هذين الجنرالين بسبب بمقابه في عام 2019
ما
ما يخص الاعتصام المدنيه وعدم اطاحه برئيس
الوزراء حمدوق واسس الحكم العسكري مره
اخرى في البلاد كان يستحقات تلك العقوبات
حينها وربما الى ازال الشرعيه عن هذين
الجنرالين
كاطراف سياسيه كنا سنحاول كل المشاكل
السودان بالتاكيد لا او هم يسيطرون على
سلاح والاموال ولا ازال قوي يعني جدا ولكن
خلال العامه نصف الماضيين ادابتكار
نفسيهما وحاول اقلاع المجتمع الدولي
والشعب السوداني من انهم قادم مدنيين
مستعدون للسلام وانهم ارتكبها الاخطاء
ويطالبون بالسماح وفي الحقيقه كل ذلك كان
كذبا شكرا
للمركز الاطلسي الامريكيه على هذه
المداخله معنا
فيما يتواصل اعلان الهدى في السودان
تتواصل عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه الدول من
البلاد لكن هذه العمليه تواجه تحديات
كثيره خصوصا على السودانيين الراغبين في
الهرب من ساحات المواجهات الى مناطق ابعد
او حتى الى خارج البلاد
تشتد الازمه هناك وتنفرج في المعابر
والموانئ والمطارات لكن قبل الوصول الى بر
الامان ثم تحديات يجب تخطيها
ولعل الوضع الامني المتردي اخطر تحدي لذا
تشكل الهدن متنفسا للحركه لكن ذلك مرهون
بالتزام طرفي النزاع بوقف اطلاق النار
فمنذ اكثر من عشره ايام اعلن عن اربع هدن
بوسطات دوليه العنوان الابرز لها خروق
وانهيار العائق الثاني في حال تجاوز الفري
نهشاشه الهدن يتمثل في كلفه التنقل فثمن
تذكره الرحله الى بورتسودان من الخرطوم في
الحافله يصل الى 400 دولار للشخص الواحد
لكن ثمه ازمه اخرى محطات وقود مغلقه اما
الانقطاع الوقود او الاستهدافها تشهد
الاسعار ارتفاعات كبيره فتكلفه الجالون في
السوق السوداء بلغت 50 دولارا اي عشره
اضعاف السعر الرسمي وللتنقل لا بد من
الدفع هنا مشكله اخرى لا
ولا صرافات اليه والبنوك مغلقه حتى تحويل
الاموال عبر تطبيقات الهواتف لا يعمل
معضله اخرى قذائف وشظايا لم تنفجر قد تكون
في انتظار اصطياد ضحيتها لذا تشدد
المنظمات على تجنب التعامل مع اي منها
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الخيارات المره والصعبه يختار
البعض المخاطره غير ان اخرين يفضلون
البقاء في منازل ستكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر
امنا من مخاطر رحله قد لا تكون محسوبه
العواقب
والان مشاهدينا الى موجز لابرز الاخبار
الدوليه بعد اول محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس
الصيني مع نظيره الاوكراني منذ بدء الحرف
في اوكرانيا اعلنت الحكومه الصينيه انها
سترسل ممثلا خاصا عن بكين مسؤولا عن
الشؤون الافريقيه الاوروبيه عفوا الاسيويه
الى اوكرانيا ودول اخرى لاجراء محادثات
معمقه مع جميع الاطراف من اجل التوصل الى
تسويه سياسيه وقال مسؤول صيني الى محادثات
جينج مع زيلينسكي تنوم عن موقف الصين
الموضوعي والمحايد اذا الشؤون الدوليه
واحساسها بالمسؤوليه
اعلنت الناطقه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه انا موسكو تقدر
استعداد بكيني بذل الجهود بشان بدء عمليه
التفاوض مع اوكرانيا واضافت ان كيف تبدي
رفضها لاي مبادرات عقلانيه تهدف الى تسويه
سياسيه ودبلوماسيه للازمه وانهاء
اعلنت روسيا عن طرد عشره دبلوماسيين
نرويجيين ردا على طرد اوسلو 15 موظفا في
السفاره الروسيه لديها وقالت الخارجيه
روسيه في بيان انها استدعت السفير
النرويجي لدى موسكو وابلغته بعمليات الطرد
هذه في اطار اجراءات انتقاميه معبره عن
احتجاجها الشديد على طرد النرويج
دبلوماسيين هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه جيمس كليفرو لانه ليس من
المرجح التغلب على كل الخلافات مع الصين
الا انه توقع ان تحافظ بكين على
التزاماتها الدوليه
يجب ان نتعامل مع الصين عند الضروره وان
نكون واقعيين بشان التعامل مع الصين وهذا
يعني عدم التراجع عن مبدا واضح لا نتوقع
ان يتم التغلب على خلافاتنا مع الصين
بسرعه لكننا نتوقع ان تراعي الصين
القوانين والالتزامات التي تعهدت بها
اعلنت رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه الى زباد
بون في البيان لها ان مشروع قانون الهجره
الذي طلب به الرئيس
الفرنسيتم تاجيله وذلك لعدم توفر التصويت
الكافي على نص القانون مما يؤجل الطرح
المفترض له واكدت ان حكومه بلادها مستعده
الى هذه المسائله كاولويه مشيره الى ان
فرنسا اعلنت عن تعبئه 150 شرطي اضافيا على
الحدود الايطاليه اعتبارا من الاسبوع
المقبل لمواجهه ضغوط الهجره المتزايده
اعلنا مسؤول امريكي ان الولايات المتحده
سترسل غواص نوويه لتتوقف في كوريا
الجنوبيه في خطوه لتعزيز قدرات الردع في
مواجهه تهديدات كوريا الشماليه هذا واكد
المسؤول الامريكي انه سيتم الاعلان عن نشر
الغواصه المجهزه بصواريخ باليسيه ذات
القدرات النوويه في اطار اعلان واشنطن
الذي سيقره الرئيس الامريكي وناظره الكوري
الجنوبي الذي يزور الولايات المتحده
والان نعود مشاهدينا الاستكمال تغطيه
احداث السودان وساعه اخباريه جديده مع
الزميله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات